[Music]  I'm Natalie and I'm saying no to sexism  Lenin I think in the coffin and I'm  saying no to her that we grew up in just  broken and doesn't allow space for women  to be leaders good interesting rules you  know you're not one of the pretty girl I  was maybe 11 or 12 that I'd expressed an  interest in doing trainings and Eversole  you cannot do boxing because you're a  girl I have a really mean right hook you  know so there's that and everyday sex is  comment which I'm sure a lot of people  get is you just you'd be prettier if you  smiled man if I have been in taxis where  the drivers will say where the woman  doesn't wanna get raped she shouldn't  bring so much aware short expect if only  we lived in a world where it wasn't our  responsibility to educate men we're not  looking to remove someone else's chances  we're just looking for an equal playing  field and I think that that's only fair  that's why we're making videos like  these you Kara will empower humanity say  no to sex